hi this is thomas flight and i'm excited
to announce that you can listen right
now to my new podcast cinema of meaning
each week fellow video essayist tom
vanderlinden from the channel likes
stories of old and i will be discussing
the philosophical themes artistry and
storytelling behind a film you can
listen to our first two episodes about
dune and the batman right now we're also
releasing the podcast as a nebula
original which means if you listen on
nebula you'll get episodes early and
ad-free on nebula you can already hear
next week's episode about the last duel
if you don't have nebula yet the best
way to get access to nebula is with the
curiosity stream bundle which i'll link
to below it's less than 15 for an entire
year i'm very excited to share these
conversations with you if you're
familiar with tom's channel you know
he's an insightful guy and i've
appreciated having his perspective on
all the films we've been discussing
there are a lot of great conversations
coming up so subscribe today to cinema
of meaning